beaucoup d'actualité cette semaine mais
on va commencer comme avec le dernier
débat de la course à la direction du
parti québécois on en parlait un peu
plus tôt une course qui tire à sa fin
dès la semaine prochaine
les membres seront appelés à voter ce
soir on retrouve michel qui assistait à
ce débat à montréal tu achètes à toronto
et daniel et à ottawa
bonsoir à vous trois enfants alors
michel je vais commencer avec vous on
parlait d'identité de langue
d'immigration qu'est ce que vous avez
retenu de ce débat où il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de débats non j'ai surtout
retenu que écouter aussi bien pour les
péquistes que pour les libéraux
d'ailleurs la course est terminée à
toutes fins utiles monsieur péladeau et
le prochain chef et on passe à l'après
course sur des sujets comme aujourd'hui
la liste est la langue si on avait eu ce
débat là il ya deux mois je suis
convaincu que le débord était pas mal
plus hardis ardue pour voir mais marie
mieux ce soir mais là c'était le calme
plat en une cette semaine il ya un petit
débat sur les mauvaises manières de
monsieur péladeau mais il est clair que
ce soit personnes avec vous d'égratigner
le futur chef
d'autant plus que le france yves
libérale elle elle est allée bien
commencé on a vu monsieur wi2wi la
commission parlementaire mais aussi
l'espèce de définition que monsieur
fourni de données de monsieur péladeau
cette semaine qu'il a décrit finalement
comme un espace de caractériel que pour
les qualités psychologiques pour hors
jeu
et un état et pour cette commission la
commission parlementaire qui va se
réunir le 26 mai et qui finalement vont
examiner tout problème delà du conflit
d'intérêts dans lequel monsieur péladeau
se placerait en devenant éventuellement
premier ministre et à contrôler un
empire médiatique comme celui là alors
là disons que les choses les plus
faciles pour monsieur péladeau sont
derrière lui et que la vraie partie va
commencer daniel jeux sont déjà faits
pour les libéraux ben oui mais les jeux
sont faits pour tout le monde
pierre karl péladeau va gagner en moi
qui ai un tremblement terre des
tremblements ter n'arrive qu'en alberta
par rapport au temps qui courent s'il
n'y a pas de doute là-dessus et la
commission parlementaire c'est une
commission bidon ultra partisane
personne n'est dupe tout le monde sait
exactement pourquoi ça va se passer
pourquoi ça va arriver
je pense moi que ça va empêcher pierre
karl péladeau dormir non à avoir un peu
ce qui s'est passé au cours des
dernières semaines les plus gros
problèmes pour monsieur péladeau
proviennent de l'intérieur de son parti
il y avait la course à la direction il
ya toujours des coups de jarnac qui se
donnent à ce genre de course et c'était
assez assez surprenant dans certains cas
il ya toute une fraction une faction du
parti québécois qui n'aiment pas
monsieur péladeau qui s'inquiètent de la
direction qu'il donnera au parti cette
frange cette frange très très social
démocrate et qui le voit aller qui se
dit est ce que c'est vraiment un bon
chef mais à michel raison le vrai
travail va commencer après la course à
la direction de course à la direction
beaucoup trop longue mais toute cette
histoire de tempérament de pierre karl
péladeau tasha est trop fort ça peut lui
nuire ou ou l'aider peut-être parce que
peut-être des gens qui pensent que ça
prend un chef fort fort peut-être mais
pas agressif écoutez c'est sûr que les
politiciens c'est pas
c'est pas des petites fleurs et on pense
à des politiciens comme paul martin qui
jurait beaucoup qui frappait les bureaux
selon ceux qui travaillent avec lui jean
chrétien qui a saisi un manifestant par
le coup est ce qu'on se rappelle de ça
alors il ya parfois des tendances
agressives ce qui moi c'est comme moi je
pense c'est important d'ailleurs c'est
que c'est la menace des agressions et je
pense que c'est là où s'en va le parti
libéral influent c'est à dire que c'est
pas un monsieur péladeau s'est pas cette
fois une personne qui peut être agressif
mais qui a traversé ces pouvoirs
d'affaires dans le monde des affaires et
dans le monde des médias pourrait
peut-être influencé et déjà affecté leur
comportement d'une façon négative alors
c'est celle-là je pense que oui s'en
vont mais écoutez ce soit monsieur
péladeau était assez posé à la fin un
peu passionné mais je pense que c'est à
lui de contrôler ses impulsions et
donnait pas droit ses adversaires de
dire qu'il est agressif
un dernier mot là-dessus michel ça peut
lui nuire ça peut l'aider jeu non je
pensais plus d'une nuit dans la mesure
où les gens s'attendent de leurs
dirigeants politiques qu'ils s atteler
et à plus forte raison du 1er mai ce qui
est un certain décorum
je lisais une chronique ce matin comme
quoi on voulait pas de dominer dégriffés
je veux bien mais entre le mineur
dégriffés le chien enragé il ya quand
même tout un espace monsieur monsieur
parizeau on pouvait pas lui reprocher de
manquer de caractère mais qu'attend dans
sa prestation de premier ministre il
était tout à fait digne et avait un
statut une allure de premier ministre et
lucien bouchard cox être se coller
aussi une stature de premier ministre à
moi j'aime bien ces politiciens un peu
baveux mais qui mais qui ne dépassent
pas certaines bornes bond passant à la
scène fédérale pas une très bonne
semaine pour le premier ministre un peu
qui revenait au pays après une visite au
moyen-orient en europe
on va regarder un bref rappel de ce qui
se passe
la vidéo a été votre série il est
extrêmement important que l'on prenne
toutes les mesures pour assurer la
sécurité de notre personnel militaire
concernant monsieur omar khadr a
évidemment nous sommes déçus de la
décision
la vérification des différences de
mcafee bon un véritable tremblement
terre politique donc en alberta on en a
parlé avec cette victoire des néo
démocrates
quel message ça envoie au gouvernement
daniel il ya poursuivre et nerveux je
pense si on s'en tient l'alberta
oublions d'eau fait oublier aux cadets
remet au essentielle a bien failli une
bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle la bonne
nouvelle ça fait pas l'unanimité mais
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent que
toute remontée du déni des
néo-démocrates va se faire au départ des
libéraux que ça amène beaucoup de votes
à la gauche et que s'ils veulent leur
pouvoir profiter dans bien des
circonscriptions pour se glisse entre
les deux et c'est lui qui en sera le
grand bénéficiaire c'est pas
scientifique mais mais la réalité
politique tend à le démontrer la
mauvaise nouvelle pour stephen harper et
et ça a été vrai pour jean charest au
québec ça a été vrai à plusieurs
reprises
séoul avait un adhérent à l'usure du
pouvoir à un moment donné les électeurs
en ont assez d'un gouvernement en place
pour history 40 ans quand même en
altérant personnes et a pu mener pour
jean charest et stephen harper dans sa
neuvième année il ya beaucoup polarisé
l'opinion but est qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ne peuvent plus le voir en
peinture
donc pour lui c'est très difficile il ya
toutes sortes de petits scandales et qui
qui s'accumulent la sphère d'eau fait de
bons exemples
kader c'est un échec ce qui s'est passé
au moyen de rien cette semaine c'était
une maladresse
bref l'usure du pouvoir c'est peut-être
le plus grand ennemi de stephen harper à
ce moment mais d'achat quand on regarde
l'ampleur de cette vague néo-démocrate
quand même dans un bastion conservatoire
est-ce que six venant apple devrait pas
commencer à s'inquiéter un peu ouais si
je ne peux se dit peut-être s'il était
en alberta irait 30 ans de plus qu'il
attendait parce que
je ne serai pas usé avant ça mais
certainement je pense que ce qui est
arrivé c'est intéressant parce que ça
donne justement un signal que oui il ya
peut-être un changement on sait que dans
les paires ciel pendant les deux
dernières années
les libéraux ont augmenté leur score de
façon significative dans l'ouest disons
pas gagné mais ils ont augmenté sur
énormément dans plusieurs
circonscriptions exactement et on voit
que peut-être et un potentiel maintenant
que six élus néo-démocrates qui sont
perçues comme celle de david contre les
goliaths que c'est eux qui vont profiter
de cette situation à cause de l'effet de
madame notre lait alors je pense que
pour monsieur europe 1 c'est comme
dernière a dit c'est pas une telle
mauvaise nouvelle est aussi au québec
c'est important parce que les québécois
aussi regarde ce qui s'est passé et ce
que ça leur dit c'est que peut-être
celle npd au lieu des libéraux qui est
important d'appuyer conserver le siège
de la fédé au québec ça fait la sphère
de monsieur harper aussi michel est ce
que ces résultats là peuvent se répandre
dans l'est du buteur dans le reste du
pays au fond est-ce que ça peut servir
un peu d'exemples
ça peut mais c'est pas évident c'est pas
automatique du tout il y avait des
circonstances vraiment propre à
l'alberta madame naples est de toute
évidence à être une personne
charismatique beaucoup plus que les
monsieur mulcair alors faire
l'adéquation c'est assez risqué de la
même façon que monsieur harper n'est pas
monsieur prentice s'est pas passé les
albertains et avec monsieur prentice n'a
pas un bon premier ministre qui vont se
détourner de monsieur rappeur alors
généralisée c'est un peu imprudent
c'est quand même une bonne nouvelle je
pense pour monsieur walker qui les
personnels dont on parlait un peu tantôt
avait prêté très glorieuse pour le npd
là le npd peut légitimement dire
regardez on peut être des gagnants on
peut être l'alternative monsieur et au
québec en particulier je pense avoir
contribué à solidifier le vote néo
démocrates parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui peuvent pas voir monsieur
harper à peinture se disait même si bon
trudeau est un peu plus inspirants qu'il
faut s'il faut en passer par là pour se
débarrasser dans un pub allons-y là
c'est plus aussi automatique que ça bon
justement parlons-en de justin trudeau
peut-être une autre mauvaise nouvelle
pour les conservateurs lancent le fait
qu'ils viennent un peu joué dans l'eure
dans leur plate blanc leurs
plates-bandes avec les baisses d'impôts
pour la classe moyenne avec cette
prestation pour enfants améliorés
simplifiés et améliorés au fond daniel
une bonne stratégie
oui mais je pense que oui je pense que
dans l'entourage de justin trudeau on a
compris qu'on n'avait pas gagné de grand
débat sur de grandes idées c'est pas la
force de justin trudeau s'est pas là où
il est à l'aise il et d'alès dans la
politique beaucoup plus populistes et là
il a il a pris deux décisions cette
semaine que son père n'aurait
probablement jamais prise de sa vie mais
qui sont politiquement intéressante pour
les libéraux ont appuyé le projet de loi
sur la sécurité
ça va empêcher les conservateurs de dire
que justin trudeau c'est l'ami des
terroristes genre de débat vous voulez
pas voir pendant une campagne électorale
et et sa sortie plus tôt cette semaine
sur l'économie avec cette aide à la
classe à la classe moyenne cette fameuse
classe moyenne ça aussi c'est ta gueule
parce que si venant peut occuper tout ce
terrain avec le fractionnement du revenu
le relèvement du celi à le plafond
derrière et c'est donc il à équilibrer
les choses en posant ses deux res c'est
pas de la grande politique ira pas de
grandes
de grandes thèses qui sont écrit
là-dessus mais c'est à des tâches à 1
c'est habile dans le sens qu'il va
cibler une partie de cette classe
moyenne qui va mieux profiter sous son
plan que celui de monsieur harper et je
pense que les électeurs vont essayer de
décortiquer est-ce que comment ça va ça
fait ça va m'affecter moi si j'étais
sous le plan de monsieur trudeau versus
monsieur ce qui est aussi bon pour
monsieur trudeau c'est qu'il utilise le
thème de l'équité sociale et la justice
comme il disait toujours pendant sa
conférence de presse
et c'est ça où il dit que les
consommateurs aient de police démunis ou
ceux qui auront besoin de l'aide mais
les riches alors pour les conservateurs
sans les remet dans une position de pas
défendre l'héritage parce que c'est
difficile mais de dire que effectivement
au site rue d'hautmont et qu'ils vont
nuire à la classe moyenne alors c'est
une bonne ça fait un vrai débat mais
c'est quand encore l'arrêt distribution
finalement michel ne reste pas beaucoup
de temps
c'est intéressant aussi pour monsieur
trudeau par rapport au npd parce que
c'est vraiment une proposition qui est
progressiste à faire payer les riches en
saas est populaire chez les électeurs du
npd et au québec
il ratisse beaucoup plus large avec sa
proposition je pense que beaucoup de
gens d'ailleurs aussi au canada mais
vont trouver ça plus intéressant qu'un
programme de garderies nationale au
québec il y en a des garderies déjà
alors les gens président et coo dont on
va prendre ce que trudeau nous offre qui
on a déjà les garderies alors c'est
doublement intéressant alors si c'est
vraiment habile de toutes les façons
c'est rare qu'on al'occasion dire que
monsieur trudeau à faire un bon un vrai
bon coup là mais je pense que c'est le
cas cette fois-ci qu on l'a attendu non
longtemps 7
ce programme économique alors très bien
donc la semaine prochaine la fin du
grand suspense au parti québécois on se
reprocher je vous demande pas voir vos
prédictions pas besoin c'est pourquoi
c'est facile belfort une fois c'est
facile mais ne pas devoir déjà noir
dentaire rio à paris
je reviens merci beaucoup michel pacha
daniel à la semaine prochaine